and now we briefly interrupt our
critique of the extra silly to salute
someone
extra special now if i suggested a sport
that literally drained your body of
life-sustaining oxygen
edging you to the very brink of
existence you'd probably say
no thanks but then you're not alessia
zucchini
aiming to dive deeper on one breath than
any female free diver has before in her
category
even at the surface the average person
runs out of breath
after little more than a minute but
alessia
is far from average
[Music]
and down at 351 feet almost the length
of a football field
she breaks the record
[Music]
surfacing after a single breath hold of
three and a half minutes
[Applause]
it's easy to forget how dangerous
swimming underwater can be
it can feel tranquil almost womb-like
until you hit a problem which in free
diving can result in
oxygen starvation nitrogen narcosis
decompression sickness
blackout all the bad stuff but while i
wouldn't advise trying to beat alessia's
record
i would recommend learning the science
behind the feet
as our free diver dives his body
consumes its oxygen supply
which can lead to a potentially lethal
blackout
in his favor is an evolutionary response
called the mammalian dive reflex
which diverts oxygen-rich blood to the
vital organs and reduces the heart rate
lowering oxygen consumption efficient
monofin technique
also helps its large surface area
displaces a lot of water
propelling him forwards with minimal
effort thereby conserving oxygen
[Music]
okay nearly ready to break some records
it's time for a quick
kit check flippers work on the same
principle as monofins
displacing water to generate propulsion
[Music]
not so good on land though all right
let's dive down where the mammalian dive
reflex kicks in
even at shallow depths
not exactly what i meant by mammalian
dive reflex
and while they'll still be experiencing
the reflex they're rather
wasting its oxygen conserving effects
that's better making the most of the
propulsion generated by his flippers
with gentle rhythmic kicks conserving
precious oxygen for the swim back up
or for riding a bike okay
let's head up but calmly and oxygen
efficiently so as to avoid
that thing all free divers fear
i was actually thinking of blacking out
but on that evidence
i think we should leave alessia's record
well alone
[Music]
you